[Music]
i'm going to talk about
uh free speech today and uh this
actually does follow up on on the
earlier session i was
involved in on truth that is what is the
nature of truth how do we know what's
true
um the problem is is we can't know for
sure
uh and no one is smart enough to figure
it out on their own
so we need to communicate with other
people thus free speech
that is to say if we think of science as
this empirical
search for truth in which we use um
experimentation and empiricism and logic
and reason and rationality
to derive conclusions about the natural
world that we assume is really out there
the problem is i can't operate on my own
uh
in isolation to do that because i'm not
smart enough and neither are you neither
is anybody else so
we need other people all we have are our
thoughts so we have to communicate those
thoughts with others
and the reason to do that is because
um there's a good chance we could be
wrong in our hypothetizing and
theorizing and guessing and
and just thinking about the world so we
have to talk to other people
and and not just talk to them but listen
to them carefully to make sure we
haven't gone off the rails
that is to say i'm going to be arguing
in this opening
session here that um this idea of open
debate disputation
conversation and that kind of free
wheeling um dialoguing with other people
uncritically that is to say no
cancel culture here we just want to talk
to other people
and they should be free to say what they
want and we should be free to listen
uh because that is the key to how
science works
and in this that sense before i dive
into the arguments for free speech that
here i'm making a case for kind of the
social nature of science that is
whatever the scientific method is and it
depends on who you're talking to about
exactly how it's enumerated
uh you know observation and deduction
and induction
and deduction and prediction and testing
and so forth
there's a social element to it that is
to say we
hope in the fullness of time to find
some kind of consensus
amongst the experts in a particular
field about what it is we think is
true true with a small t
uh provisionally true that is to say um
there's enough evidence for it that it
would be reasonable to offer our
provisional assent
with the proviso that we can change our
mind if the evidence changes
well the only way to to reach consensus
is to talk to other people so
scientific communities have to have a
certain kind of openness and freedom
to speak their minds and that's the
basis of
peer review for example or open peer
commentary
where the say article is submitted to
some blind reviewers
that is to say uh they don't know who
you are you don't know who they are
so that people are free to speak their
mind and not worry about offending
somebody because the moment you start
worrying about that sort of thing
you self-censor you don't say what
you're really thinking
and that's very dangerous for science in
particular and for just trying to
understand truth in general
because you might have gone off the
rails and if somebody is afraid to tell
you because
maybe you have too much power you're in
a position
at a university or in a lab in which
they're afraid to tell you
that they think you're wrong then that's
very dangerous
so that's kind of the basis of it if you
think of consensus
science not as a form of
authoritarianism or democracy
because that's not what i mean i mean
that the people that are best qualified
to understand a particular phenomenon
under
study say climate science and they're
competitive with each other
and they have kind of an open
marketplace where they can debate
the merits of the different theories
say co2 gases in the atmosphere and
whether or not that causes
warming to increase at some point over
the course of years
or decades consensus has reached that
you know we
most of us think x is the case in this
case with
anthropogenic global warming we think
it's largely human caused
and real and uh so you often see this
figure like 97 percent of
climate scientists think uh agw is is
true
these are the most qualified people who
compete with
each other and try to debunk each other
in the
pages of scientific journals and what
emerges is this kind of general
consensus of course it's never going to
be 100
that's fine progress is made in science
again through that
uh open debate disputation free exchange
marketplace of ideas as it were and
and of course that's the basis of of a
liberal democracy we all have to be able
to be free to say what we're thinking
and then we come down to running the
experiment as it were
in this case uh having an election so
um my latest book is on this subject
giving the devil is due
the devil is whoever disagrees with you
and what the devil is due is their voice
their thoughts they should be free to
think and say whatever they want
because um well i'm gonna enumerate
those
in uh ten different reasons so here is
here's the
kind of my articulation of why we should
give the devil is two
with that background on how science
works but i would apply that to anything
so um that is to say the moment you
decide
um i don't think everybody should be
free to say whatever they want i think
we should have some um some
censorship okay well who decides which
speech
and thought is acceptable and which is
unacceptable
you me the majority the thought
committee
the language police the control of
speech is how dictatorships and
autocracies rule
we must resist the urge to control what
other people think
and say second reason what criteria
are you going to use to censor
somebody's speech are these ideas that i
disagree with
ideas that you disagree with uh are they
thoughts that differ from the mainstream
uh
thoughts of the community uh is it
whatever the majority says
is true that's that's the the speech
we're going to uh
respect and then anyone who descends
from that we're going to censor
the problem with that is what's called
the tyranny of the majority
uh which is why we do not have at least
in the united states
a direct democracy the problem with the
direct democracy is the tyranny of the
majority you just need 51
to say well we think slavery is a good
thing so let's bring it back
no we're not going to do that and
there's reasons we're not going to do
that
and it doesn't matter how many people
think so we have a representative
uh democracy a republic actually anyway
three it's not just the right of the
speakers to speak
of course but it is but more than that
it's the right of listeners to listen
so when college students de-platform
uh speakers uh that have been invited
to come to a campus to give their point
of view
some new theory or topic or book or
whatever
and uh and the students protest and the
and the speech is canceled or
perhaps even worse the speaker actually
goes there
flies there and has to stay in a hotel
and so forth and then
shows up to give their talk and and then
the um
the mob uh silences them um
through you know noisemakers and
shouting and chanting and so forth
well it's not just violating the rights
of the speaker to speak but the audience
to hear
maybe a lot of students came there to
hear what this person has to say
now most college campuses are pretty
liberal
and some college campuses bring in
conservatives just
so the students can see what
conservatives think you know
what half the country thinks maybe it's
good that they should know what half the
country's thinking
and uh and so by silencing
um the speaker then you're robbing your
fellow students
of their right to hear what that other
perspective is just because you're
offended
so what too bad um okay
number four and here the next couple
points i'm kind of echoing jon stewart
mills arguments from his
classic 1859 work on liberty
we might be completely right but still
learn something new
in hearing what someone else has to say
or five we might be partially right and
partially wrong
and by listening to other viewpoints we
might stand corrected and refine and
improve our beliefs
or six we might be completely wrong so
hearing criticism or counterpoint gives
us the opportunity to change our minds
and improve our thinking no one is
infallible
the only way to find out if you've gone
off the rails is to get feedback on your
beliefs
opinions and even your facts
number seven whether you're right or
wrong by listening to the opinions of
others we have the opportunity to
develop stronger arguments
and build better facts in our positions
if you know only your own position you
do not know it as well as you would if
you knew your
opponent's position here this is jon
stewart mills famous
line from on liberty he who knows only
his own side
doesn't even know that and uh so here i
use an example
um of the abortion issue so you know
most of my
students at chapman university where i
teach
are liberal so they're pro-choice on the
abortion issue
and you know i like to ask them what are
the best arguments that the pro-lifers
have
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas
you